our street's pretty
packed these days there's a lot of
people parking on the street but there
are also snickerdoodles parking on the
street
do you own a green volkswagen
no okay
park right in front of the fire door
wait what
huh
what
i don't know
are you really
what if someone was in a wheelchair what
if there was a fire
[Music]
why did you suddenly get so angry over
this
i've been angry about this
it's also the only exit to this building
for two dozen people the order of steve
himself don't park in front of a
subscribe door
[Music]
i heard you started a print
i did start a print after talking with
the red guys you know i was like okay
i've kind of actually spent the last few
years here going yeah lenses they're all
the same whatever it's like if they're
in focus that's that's all i really care
about i decided to you know i flip that
around a little bit so i actually got a
new vintage lens should be arriving in a
couple days i ordered a helios 442 see
the weird swirly bokeh effect there this
cool like kind of like swirl bulge to
all your bokeh effect i don't know
exactly what creates that quality but
i've only found it in two lenses
so that led me down a further hole of
like you know i love anamorphic lenses
because okay so when you're filming a
narrative it's fiction sometimes i feel
like the clearer you can see something
on screen the less
fictional it seems sometimes i don't
know it's hard to describe it's like the
clearer the lens in which you are
viewing a scene through the less mystery
finding a way to shape the image so you
can create a barrier a barrier between
reality and fiction lenses that don't
give you that perfect mathematically
clean approach adds to that a lot got
this vintage lens coming in here and in
the meantime i'm also going to be
printing out a bunch of like anamorphic
style mods basically just oval bokehs to
try out on the other lenses because even
that
starts to give that effect these ones
are gonna go on the front these guys are
selling these filters for like 150 bucks
but you can see that they're 3d printed
and they stopped selling them they don't
they don't make them anymore they ran
out of filament
yeah i guess so oh there it is you can
see that yeah it's only a ticket it's
only gonna take an hour to print this
too there's two reasons i think this
kind of stuff is very effective one a
lot of older movies were shot with
anamorphic lenses so simply seeing an
image that resembles those old movies
kind of creates that feeling of like
film nostalgia even if you are not a
cinephile there's something deep down in
your brain that clicks and you're like
oh okay i get it indiana jones i think
it helps people just slip into that
cinematic experience a little bit more
quickly and then once again the concept
of the barrier if your lens is too clean
you don't have really as much of a
barrier between reality and fiction by
stylizing how you're capturing the image
i think that really helps people kind of
get into a story a little bit more
so an hour later that was great that was
great this is a one hour print look at
that look at that little hole there
we're gonna film a shot through this
let's see if it looks different at all
because if this if this looks decent
then i'm gonna go through and i'm gonna
make permanent rigs for all this stuff
this is gonna save us thousands and
thousands of dollars of sam's crazy
vintage lens shopping spree if it
doesn't work then the shopping spree is
on and we're gonna lose all our money so
the way bokos work is basically all i'm
doing here is just shaping the light
before it hits the sensor a little bit
more currently there is a circular
aperture that's how the light is hitting
the lens as a circle i'm going to throw
an oval shape on there and ideally light
now starts being shaped by this and as i
go out of focus we will see this shape
instead of a circle emulating the
anamorphic look so it's doing stuff
right now but it's not as intense as i
wanted it to be but it's still pretty
pretty cool it's not having it's not the
most dramatic thing right now in the
world but it's certainly functioning i
think what i'm going to do is just print
one more right now and then overall just
like shrink this in half basically
so we have a crisis not only is ren's
one wheel mountain on fire
but i broke the 24 millimeter lens
[Music]
you